the UFC's in trouble cuz they're not
able to [ __ ] put up their nights I
know I don't know why it's adamant about
it bad well they're gonna be in times
like in Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia do it
do what you got to do Cova doesn't
doesn't grow in that kind of weather do
we do we know so that it's going forward
khabib Ferguson will see that I go
forward you have location for wow this
is on Monday it's true the prosciutto
will do things power to preserve the
highly anticipated title fight with Tony
Ferguson will see the chip seven
together
Dean's going to send this location yeah
I don't know we definitely don't set New
York red the hotbed for they already
said for sure
that's not going to be in New York
Barclays they're gonna have to go across
seas
yeah I can imagine doing it like UAE
yeah yeah do they have problems out
there I know we heard of any case in
Saudi Arabia Middle East and stuff it's
everywhere no call just close because I
am buddy the hold on so how is this it's
spelled just kung fu kung fu' yeah
you're saying umph well that's how it's
said so as I'm from I studied in China
pistol